welcome back the national senior games
are happening from July 7th through the
18th so it's the largest multi-sport
event in the world for athletes over the
age of 50. a group honored as Humana
game changers will be among those going
for the gold we spoke with both a senior
games gold medalist and a two-time
Olympic gold medalist to learn more
about these exciting games and the push
for healthy aging
diet sour a 13-time senior games athlete
and two-time recipient of humana's Game
Changer award says it's never too late
to be an athlete I did not compete in
anything although I admired athletes and
I loved Sports
when I was 58 years old I was in the
locker room of the fitness club where I
worked out and heard someone talking
about Senior Games Teresa Andrews a
two-time Olympic gold medalist and
member of humana's leadership team says
now is the time to start training for
the next senior games but I think it
just takes one step at a time in a start
I wasn't supposed to make the Olympic
team and I was never supposed to win a
gold medal I love working with seniors
and getting them to believe and start
it's never too late you can also go out
to the nsga website which is the
national Senior Games website and you
can see local resources in each of your
States how to qualify for the national
senior games but also getting ideas on
whatever your interest is
thank you to Humana for sponsoring this
segment Las Vegas now we'll be right
back